Game Pass offers hundreds of games with
more being added every month but don't
worry in this video we're going to go
over what's new and some gems worth
checking out on Microsoft's gaming
service
the ones PlayStation 5 exclusive is now
on Xbox game pass that's right I am
talking about death Loop you play as
cult an amnesic trapped in a day-long
Time loop on a mysterious island called
black Reef which is run by eight
eccentric villains known as Visionaries
call is being haunted and killed over
and over again by someone named Juliana
the objective of the game kill all eight
Visionaries in a single day to break the
loop and try and stay alive while doing
so if you're not familiar Arcane are the
devs behind games like Dishonored and
prey both of which are also available on
Game Pass and death Loop is its most
ambitious game to date it's a
culmination of all design principles
with an intricately designed systematic
World special powers and an open-ended
approach to play styles with one major
addition set in a Time Loop death Loop
is announced for the PS5 before
Microsoft acquired Bethesda making it an
exclusive to the fancy new next-gen
console in the PlayStation series but no
more now it's on the other fancy
next-gen console
and PC which it has been
um for a while now anyway it was
gamespot's 2021 game of the year so for
you non-playstation players out there
Now's the Time to jump into one of
arcane's most well received games it
just oozes coolness and when you're done
playing it I highly recommend you watch
this video I did on the game's
Troublesome production that led to an 11
hour redesign that made it the game it
is today you should watch it card in the
corner to check it out
over the past few years Boomer Shooters
have been on the rise again I know I
don't mean shooting games that involve
50 to 70 year old people navigating the
commas of Facebook but the fast-paced
genre of Shooters made popular in the
90s that evolve lots of moving and
shooting waves and waves of enemies that
explode into mounds of Flesh and make
you feel like a real sweet dude named
something simple like Doom God Proteus
is exactly that but new while still
retaining enough of that nostalgic tinge
with filters and 360p resolution and
Sprite enemies to blow up and since it's
a boomer shooter that means it has a
boomer riffin metal soundtrack to make
you feel like a cool Proteus guy I don't
know if the guy you play as is actually
named anything but I don't care because
to me he's just Proteus guy now anyways
the game riffs with lots of guts guns
and guitars the three G's as I call them
the essential stamp for all Boomer
Shooters I've been playing this game a
bunch recently and you know what I don't
know what it's about but it makes me
feel cool so that's enough for me
[Music]
and while we're on the topic of the
three Big G's metal helsinger which is
very much as close as one can get to
guts guns and guitars with an emphasis
on guitars 2016's Doom didn't just put
Boomer Shooters back on the map by
revolutionizing the genre altogether it
also gave us a kick-ass metal soundtrack
that in its own right was just as
influential it was a beautiful marriage
in Flow State action set to the hardest
pulsing metal riffs it was so damn good
it basically inspired a whole new genre
of Rhythm first person shooter games
like BPM bullets per minute and now
metal hellsinger
metal helsinger however is taking the
metal part very seriously its soundtrack
is bolstered with heavy metal Talent
from Trivium arch enemy and Lamb of God
just to name a few you'll have to rip
and tear your way through demons and
monsters to the rhythm of the music
shooting on cue while your eardrums are
decimated
[Music]
let's keep things dark brooding and
violent Moon scars doesn't feature all
the triple G's of the previous games we
talked about but it has one of the G's
and all capital letters and that is guts
Moon scars is a 2d metroidvania set in a
grim and unrelenting world where you
play as a warrior made of Clay hell-bent
on finding the sculptor who made her and
to understand why she was brought into
this Gothic Maca moonlit world in the
first place you'll have to use a
plethora of weapons to Splatter your
foes into bits and master special
abilities to navigate this non-linear
brutal and dark action game and the
animation is just super sick enemies are
twisted scary and Fantastical that'll
have your palms sweating in some intense
fights and in typical metroidvania
tradition you'll have to be getting new
powers in order to find new areas and
fight different enemies
woof have we found our way into some
dark brooding corners on this list let's
brighten things up a bit shall we
because sure maybe every once in a while
you just want to brood around and get
drenched in the blood of your enemies
and other times you just want to hop
into a colorful world and journey
through a place called rainbow Island
where Wiggly's slimy things are living
creatures that are as happy as happy can
be the Slime Rancher 2 you're not
tearing things apart with your bare
hands to some sweet metal riffs instead
you're collecting these adorable happy
balls of goo and making a paradise for
you and them to live it features loads
of unique and vibrant environments to
explore and tons of slime types to meet
along the way being a sequel it of
course has new locations and slimes and
also just in general it's a pleasant and
easy going change of pace if you need it
from you know the guts guns and guitars
of the other games we've talked about
it might look like we're going on the
upswing of cute stuff but don't be
deceived because while Beacon Pines is
filled with Whimsy animals and cool
outfits it's also riddled with mystery
and a creepy adventure to set out on
Beacon Pines is displayed as an
interactive book and in a really cool
twist you play as the reader and the
main character of its story Luca you'll
guide Luke around the story's
environments investigating all its
Corners talking to its many characters
but you'll also be navigating an
interactive story tree that branches in
many different ways depending on your
choices and in doing so exploring
different outcomes becomes a part of the
game's narrative leading you to
flip-flop through different versions of
the story in order to see the full
picture of its mystery that's a pretty
neat way to handle branching outcomes
the last game on the list some would say
is an oldie at this point but far from
out of date despite taking place nearly
3 000 years ago Assassin's Creed Odyssey
is now on Game Pass this is the
follow-up to the franchise's big leap
into the RPG realm after Origins which
is also on Game Pass curling the Mythos
into ancient Greece Odyssey put an
emphasis on player choice along with the
player more agency to decide the path
they wanted to take and the type of hero
they wanted to become carrying forward
the RPG elements Odyssey allows players
to customize their equipment and build
out new special abilities to fit their
playstyle now this is some speculation
but considering that Assassin's Creed
Origins was added to Game Pass only
earlier this year and now honestly I
can't help but assume that maybe just
possibly will be seeing Assassin's Creed
Valhalla joining the ranks soon too so
here's to hoping
all right that's September for Game Pass
a month filled with guns guts guitars
cute animals slimy friends brooding
worlds and a rainbow Island the list of
Xbox game pass games just keeps on
growing so why not get out there and try
something new who knows maybe slime
Rancher will awaken something in you you
didn't know you needed or you'll realize
that Proteus is a sort of blood-soaked
romp you need at the end of a long day
like a warm bath
filled with blood
backpack
[Music]